[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today he is the host of the ken
coleman show here on the ramsey networks
where he talks about career and talks
about jobs and uh how to get one of each
and uh hopefully one in the same
wouldn't be a bad idea yeah so if you
want to talk about that and your life
and your money we're here to help the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
two
selena is with us in dallas texas hi
selena how are you
hi thanks for taking my call dave sure
what's up
so my question is for kent
i kind of need help deciphering where
exactly i'm supposed to
go in the area of nursing so a little
bit of background
i am a registered nurse i started out my
first job in a stroke unit
and um
so my first
job in the job that i actually resigned
from
i got it in 2018 and i resigned just
this year
in january just because of the burnout
it was a very heavy job that i just
it was costing me to get out of bed and
heading to work
but there's so many areas of nursing
that i would like to explore but i need
just kind of like direction
into you know
picking out exactly where i'm sure
so let's first identify
what specifically caused you to feel
burnout in that last job i think you
said heavy was it the nature of the
patients and what you were dealing with
what was the specific cause of burnout
in that last nursing job
definitely so with stroke patients
adult stroke patients there's
you know
a lot of
debilitating debilitating after
math after having a stroke so it was
a lot of dependent stuff that they
needed um
i did enjoy
giving the care providing the care
um it may have also just been the
environment that i was in
management specifically um
there wasn't a lot of
just i would think equality
and so i had a little bit to deal with
it i enjoyed though good so okay so
here's the deal it's first of all i
don't want you to have any guilt and you
haven't mentioned that you have but i
want to make sure i address this because
we hear this a lot uh from callers who
are thinking about making a switch
you don't need to feel in any way a
sense of guilt or shame over that
particular type of nursing work really
kind of eating away at you emotionally
it's really really tough heavy stuff you
are a caregiver you just use that word
and so nursing is caregiving so really
this is about exploring all the
different types of nursing and you know
all the different types of nursing and
you're exploring all of them and i want
you having real conversations with other
nurses to get from them almost like you
would if you were to interview somebody
back in high school about a profession
and sit down and the ins and the outs
the good the bad the ugly about that
particular type of nurse eating here's
what's going to happen as your brain
gathers the information that's the logic
side
your heart
begins to filter that logical
information and your heart's going to
warm and kind of go ding ding ding to
the type of caregiving the specific
people that you're giving care to and so
you know you've got to look at
everything you know
one of my best friends in the world his
wife is a nicu nurse she
she loves taking care of those little
babies
that are just fighting with everything
they got it's not too heavy for her it
gives her great lift and joy uh but you
know i know there's all kinds of nurses
there's the nurses who check you in
before surgeries it's highly
administrative you've got nurses that
are dealing with trauma in the er you've
got all different kind of nursing and i
think you've got to be in a place where
you go i'm giving care
but i'm giving care
to people that when i care for them and
their particular situation i'm lifted as
opposed to feeling like it's too heavy
does that make sense
yeah so this is just simple discovery
good old-fashioned conversations over
coffee and you've got all the
connections you're already in and you're
already qualified and just follow your
heart to this
you already know don't you
i did i was influenced into nursing
because i had a heart surgery when i was
three so pediatrics is where
i feel like i could go into it's just
i fear that it's gonna negatively affect
me emotionally just because i am a home
mom now as a toddler and a newborn
so i don't want to be
it's a it's fearful to be affected
emotionally
you know what i mean sure you know one
of the things i would suggest is that
you maybe uh
take a couple of sessions with a
therapist and a counselor somebody
that's a professional and talk about how
uh when you're in that caregiving
function
how you are essentially projecting
some of those scenarios into your own
life talk to somebody professionally
about that because i think there are
some tools that can help you uh enjoy
the work but not carry so much of it
with you but you're going to need help
it's hard to do that on your own
hey good question selena thank you for
calling in open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five joe is
in salt lake city utah hi joe how are
you
good thanks for taking my call
better than we deserve brother what's up
have a question um
we
are close to paying off our mortgage and
being debt free completely
the approach we've been taking is
probably a little different than what
you would recommend i would say because
we've just barely discovered you not too
long ago just from friends but anyways
um what we've been doing is putting my
entire paycheck towards the mortgage and
um and some
above that and then living off my wife's
paycheck
we have a low interest rate of 2.3
i'm just wondering if it's smart to
continue what we're doing just dumping a
load onto it
compared to just paying just a little
bit at a time but and when we're all
done with all this we should be
according to our math and calculators
online we should have it paid off in
seven months if we
keep going the way we are that's one
part
i assume you're debt-free other than the
house
yeah okay do you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
we have uh
fifteen thousand dollars in savings
what's your household income
uh 150 000 okay it's probably a little
slim
a little less than three to six months
but probably pretty close you're
probably all right and the only
difference is i i wouldn't define it by
paycheck i would just put both paychecks
in a total at the top of the page
and i would throw as much of that as you
can at this mortgage
and in a sense that's the same thing
you're doing but and then instead of
saying uh we're gonna put my check and a
little of my wife's towards it we're
just gonna put the equivalent of those
two things towards it out of your budget
um and we do recommend you put 15 of
your income into retirement while you're
doing this and that might make it nine
months instead of
seven to pay off the mortgage but you're
you're not doing anything wrong here man
you're heading in the right direction
everything's going the right way
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just thirty dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've been trying to
pay off debt i know it feels like you're
the only one
who feels this level of weight
it can be really lonely it can be really
frustrating but you're not alone lots of
people are tackling their debt too
and they're feeling the same way you are
you don't have to be by yourself while
you're doing this join a financial peace
university class with other people
together you'll learn the power of the
proven plan to win with money
and the accountability the encouragement
the encouragement
the encouragement it's a big deal you
celebrate with other people as you make
progress
right now there's hundreds of virtual
classes and hundreds of in-person
financial peace university classes
starting all over the country
you can join your choice of them
find people that are doing what you're
doing they want to be debt free so that
they can build wealth and be
outrageously generous you can get access
to the class and more tools only with a
ramsey plus membership
financial peace university is part of
ramsey plus start your free trial of
ramsey plus by texting trial 233 789
text trial 233
seven
eight nine
up next is going to be shane in
greenville south carolina hi shane how
are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
well i have a quick question for you um
me and my husband are on baby step two
and we're down to our last two remaining
debts um one is uh carlin
and we're trying to figure out if we
should um trade that car in and have the
loan paid off and buy a car in cash
um because if we do that you know we'll
be closer to um just having our last
debt which is our student loan debt
and we should be finished paying that by
the end of the year how much do you owe
on the car
we owe um 11 300. okay
and uh what's your household income
uh 50 000
okay and do you like the car
we do it's a 2017 toyota corolla it has
89 000 miles on it
um
but it's a good car um when i looked it
up on carvana or like kelly's book they
said we could give us around 11 000 for
it yeah the two rules of thumb that we
use on whether you need to sell a car
are
number one can you be debt free
everything but the house within two
years from today i think you can
if you keep the car
do you
yeah okay
number two is all of your vehicles added
together everything with um
motors and wheels
of any kind added together equal more
than half your annual income and unless
you have an another car in the driveway
that's really expensive this you're not
violating that rule either
right now we have a
2008 honda odyssey as well yeah so i'm
keeping it
okay and fight fight on through it's
just going to add a few months to your
debt snowball
uh but uh you're going to have a
reasonably good car when you're done
there that's something that's not out of
control if you told me the car was 33
000 i'd have sold it already okay
okay because that would have been more
than half your annual income and you
wouldn't have been able to pay it off
with the student loans in two years
right
right it would it would have been the
impact it would have been too big of an
impediment this is not a big enough move
of the needle unless you just already
hate the car
to get rid of it it doesn't make sense
chris is in boise idaho hi chris welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can can i
help have a question
i we my wife and i are in the process of
trans transitioning ownership from my
father-in-law's company
and we've been in talks of how
essentially my wife and i would
pay off my
brother-in-law's as their inheritance
when my in-laws pass away i'm wondering
how do we
save for that
okay uh you you're buying the company or
not
not buying it it's being passed down to
us
but how do
and it's not being passed down to you
it's being passed down to you but you
still don't own it all half of it is
going to be passed to the
brother-in-law
not officially officially we would be
owners on paper on paper but as
i guess what i'm wondering is there
quote-unquote inherent inheritance as if
my wife and i weren't being passed
the company wasn't being passed to us
and my in-laws just died one day and the
business gets sold off and we would all
get 25 percent
but since my wife and i are going to be
owners of the company
how do we go about
saving to
pay off her brothers
why do her brothers need to be paid off
it's not their company
you're getting it before you're getting
it before death and you're going to be
the owner of it
and then they die there's nothing
there's nothing owed to the brothers i
don't understand this doesn't make sense
that's the agreement that we've been in
talks
with my in-laws about what is the what
is the agreement equitable they're going
to give you the company now but when
they die you have to be you have to give
money to your brother-in-law
as part of their inheritance yes
no
i don't want the company
this is screwed up okay this is a mess
i i just what a mess
no
they don't i mean
so what happens if you grow the company
to double before they die
that is a question that needs to be
asked and that's why i'm calling to ask
you before we have this structure is
screwed
this is a bad structure
so what's this company worth
don't you generally say four times
net profit net profit for the owner yeah
that would put it right now
right around a million and a quarter
okay
so what instead i would suggest you do
is if they're gonna give you a fourth of
it and you have to buy out three-fourths
then 75 of a million and a quarter is
what you owe your parents-in-law and you
need to pay that out of profits as fast
as you possibly can give them 100 of the
profits above you making a living wage
until you get to that number and that's
that number is about 800 000 bucks
and so you're saying the problem you're
saying the profits after right i'm sorry
sorry i interrupted keep keep going
that's okay what do what'd you say
so then it's their money and they can do
what they want with it yeah then they
can leave that money to the
brother-in-law
great i just had to think about it out
loud with someone who was not involved
yeah this is the the way they're doing
it is uh it's bass backwards and you're
going to get them you're going to get
caught in the crosshairs here this is
not going to be good
so um
somebody's going to pissed off is what's
going to happen here and really really
bad so
what we suggest you do if you're buying
out a business is that you don't do
payments and you don't do debt but i
would suggest you set up your
a
minimum living wage that you can live
out of the business on
reasonably and give a hundred percent of
the profits above that wage to your
father-in-law
until it reaches that number which is
should be 75 of a million and a quarter
so we'll call it uh 800 900 000 whatever
it is and it sounds like the profits are
about 400 right
about 300 yes depending on the year yeah
and so you'd be clear in three years
maybe four but somewhere in there you'll
be clear
and and you're not obligated to give
them anything except 100 of the profits
above the living wage until you reach
that number when you reach that number
they're paid off and then there is no
strings attached to this company no one
has you don't have any obligation after
that
they can leave that other money to the
other kids and you've already gotten
yours
your share when you when they knocked
fourth off of the company
price that makes sense
absolutely yeah that's a much better
structure it's not going to get you
caught in the middle here and then if
they die before you're paid out this the
agreement still stands
the heirs the other three boys will get
the same thing they that the
parents-in-law would have gotten from
you because that that piece of paper
survives them
that deal survives them
uh and it doesn't it doesn't change
anything
[Music]
yeah that's uh um
yeah yeah that that's a much better idea
let's get this over with in other words
yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage laurie is with us hi
lori how are you hi dave i'm doing great
good welcome good to have you where do
you live i live in a suburb of
minneapolis which i affectionately refer
to as a land of snow and ice
yes it is
well welcome to nashville so good to
have you and all the way down here to do
a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off i've paid off about 100 or 41
000 in the last year
141 or 41 000 41 000 in one year
good for you and your range of income
during that year um it started out at
125 000 and now it's about 130 000. good
for you what do you do for a living i
work in clinical research okay so i help
run drug studies for new companies good
good busy year yes a lot of kovid stuff
going on yeah i can imagine i can
imagine what kind of that was the 41k um
it started about about 10 years ago i
got divorced and my ex-husband all of a
sudden he was gone and i had a mortgage
and two little kids
in five years
sorry
i was laid off three times and got
divorced so life was hard yeah
and then i was chaperoned a field trip
school field trip for my kid and i was
on the bus ride home and shout out to
dave carlson he asked you follow dave
ramsey i said who's this dave ramsey guy
where's he going if i'm gonna follow him
where's he going
um so he introduced me to you i bought
your book i i kicked it into high gear
and then about two years ago i have this
bathroom that's been unfinished for 10
years so my ex-husband gutted it all of
a sudden he was gone i look at that
bathroom i know you have t uh two
daughters i don't know if you've ever
had to share a bathroom with your
teenage daughters but it is not pleasant
i don't even it wasn't even pleasant
when they had to share one much less
with me no so i've always said i want to
finish that bathroom i just want to
finish that bathroom and finally i'm
like everyone said well just take out a
home equity loan i said no dave won't
approve of that and they're like well
forget about dave just take out a home
equity loan i'm like no i got to follow
dave
so then about two years ago i said i got
to pay off that mortgage so i put
together a plan i made double mortgage
payments that was my goal was to pay it
off in 18 months and i managed to do it
nine months you paid off your house
yes
the whole house
the whole freaking thing yeah so and
then after i did that i've been taking
all that money and throwing it into my
savings so come january i will no longer
have to share a bathroom with my two
teams
touchdown
i love it i'm teenage bathroom free yeah
yeah
way to go so you paid off your house and
everything you're so weird i love it
yeah and you can't share that with
everybody but that's why i'm here right
to share with you this is a place you
can share it with everybody everybody
here that's watching this is happy for
you yeah well done so what's this house
worth
um it's worth about 350 000 dollars wow
plus or minus a bathroom wow yes and now
the goal then is to cash free uh cash
flow to college for the kids so they're
13 and 16 so and look at you and
teaching them well right my daughter has
a job a third of her paycheck goes to
her college fund we're still working on
the budgeting but i know your donald
rachel had budget problems so there's
hope for right
turns out okay mine will too she turned
out she teaches it now yeah i know wow
look at you way to go yeah so there's
still a tremendous amount of emotion in
you as you took us back to that
catalytic moment
uh to all the single women single moms
out there
that have heard the message
maybe they got a book maybe they listen
to the podcast they watch the show
whatever and they're going i i it makes
sense but i don't think i can do it what
would you say to that single mom you
just got to keep working i mean i had a
side hustle i still do it i sell brats
and beer at major league football games
and baseball games and i always say
manual label keeps me humble
you know i'm no better than the other
person on the side of the counter they
don't know i'm debt free they might
think i'm a nobody but i'm not
and so just keep keep trying keep
plugging away and you'll get there yeah
that's so good
go vikings i'm guessing right yeah you
you know the trauma yeah the interesting
thing is the trauma is in the rearview
mirror right yeah yeah it is it's
awesome and you're driving away
yeah
what does it mean to you i mean i know
you're debt free but this emotion is is
really you celebrating what you've
overcome how much stronger are you
as a result of walking through this
debt-free journey
well i look at myself when i my husband
was gone and i was nothing i had no
self-esteem
um he had to be removed from the house
by a restraining order things were bad
so it's really hard but i look at my
kids
and i have to show them that i can do it
because they have to do it sometime too
so my motivation was my daughters
and i look at them and they're turning
into great young women they're both
taller than me that's a little hard for
me to handle but i'll get used to it
and that was my motivation and i say to
all single moms like if i can do it you
can do it yeah
yeah it's scary and it's hard but it's
doable yeah it is that's what it comes
down to and you're a hero kiddo yes well
done you completely tackled this and
just knocked the door down that's just
fabulous
very very well done okay what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
no credit card debt pay everything in
cash don't listen to everyone else who
says just take out that loan i own four
i've had four cars my entire life i've
paid cash for every single one
keep them till they die i don't care if
you think i drive an old jalopy it's
paid for
and your house is paid for yes and
you're how old i am 49. so the goal was
to pay it off by the time i turned 50
and i did it and i did it you have a 300
000 paid for house you're so weird
weird is good you're awesome
you are so awesome yeah because
everybody's broke and everybody's got an
opinion about your money it's hilarious
to me how how people can't mind their
own business you know it's just nuts so
way to go think they do go just powerful
powerful story
very well done the resilience that
you've shown and the fight that you've
shown is what's so impressive in this
absolutely i think people want to know
this is not debt related but when the
new bathroom is finished what are you
most excited about not seeing from your
from your daughters that you have to
deal with now when you walk into your
bathroom and it's just yours there's no
crap on the sink there's no retainer
there's no like 50 rings and jewelry and
speaker sitting there blaring taylor
swift
taylor swift i don't mean to knock her
but
there's only so much you can take right
yes
hey whatever motivates you dave you know
that was a powerful motivator yeah well
and then you know you're in a position
to cash flow their college they don't
have any college debt
and so you're breaking the cycle you're
breaking the chain and um there's no way
that they walk they see you walk through
this and they're not uh
inspired by you but also transformed
themselves yeah into more confident
young women and so because they get to
watch their mom the warrior princess
uh don't go into attack mode here so
well done
very well done oh there's the whole gang
yeah just saw him pop up on youtube
there very good
good stuff well done well done we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is the next chapter in your story
awesome i want to hear from you when
you're a baby steps millionaire you're
not that far now you'll be there before
getting there yeah you'll be there
before you know it with a paid for 300
000 house and retirement starting to
build up now yep all of these things are
starting to happen so very very well
done good work and a copy total money
makeover
in case you're on a bus ride somewhere
and somebody says you need to follow
dave ramsey you can hand it to him right
i will pass it on definitely because
mine is i have my own copy as well there
you go good stuff so very very well done
all right laurie from minneapolis
minnesota debt-free house and everything
41 000 paid off in the last year making
125 to 1 30. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two one i'm dead
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done
wow
let me tell you uh
you know regardless of your political
uh assignment to things we do know this
that 78
of the single moms live below the
poverty level
so that's extraordinary talk about how
you get there you can talk about how you
get out of there we can talk about
macroeconomics or are discussing all
kinds of different things around that
subject but uh we just know because we
work with so many single moms through
our coaching programs our financial
peace university you work with them on
getting jobs
and um so getting that income going like
she has done yes fabulously managing
that income
and creating this result by the time
she's 49 years old very impressive
heroic heroic that's the word that's
what heroes do they're heroic that's
right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
patty is in new york city hi patty
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so i have a question um pertaining to
student loans so
when i was 18 i'm 21 right now when i
was 18 i went away to college
made the mistake of getting myself in
student loans but i didn't finish with a
degree
so i currently am 54 000 in debt with
just an associate's degree because i
ended up going to
suffolk county community college and i
ended up just getting
you know my basic degree
so my question is is that i'm
deciding on going back to school but
the school that i want to go to will put
me
in more debt again but it will also give
me a very stable job no well
schools don't give stable jobs that's bs
yeah you have to go earn it
what do you want to do what's the job
that you think is stable that you're
looking for
i want to be an ultrasound tech which um
it it's very specific very hands-on so i
can't just go anywhere and like be
trained for it i specifically would have
to go to
a program for two years in order to get
the chance to even start the career how
much is that program going to cost that
you've researched
um so it's originally forty thousand
dollars but i know i would be
definitely like able to get financial
aid i'm just not sure how much and i
know it definitely wouldn't be the
entire cost
and what does an ultrasound tech make
in new york they make easily 80 to 90
000 a year
on average they can make even more
depending on experience and location who
said
where'd you get that information
well there it is dave that's uh in stone
because google said it
yeah all right um
what do you do now what do you make now
um i'm a part-time cashier at a grocery
store i make seventeen dollars an hour
okay what what is your associate's
degree in
uh liberal arts so
it's nothing specific it was general
studies
okay
uh quick question on uh how much
a do you think you would be able to get
financial aid so how much off of the 40
000 at this one program would you be
able to get off
um i was looking into it and
it would be about
um i can't remember oh it was 14 000 a
year so 28 in total okay that's that's a
whole lot better 14 000 a year
so
uh the next question is have you done
any research to see if there are other
competitive programs or other options
that will get you the same certification
or training
um i have
uh like i said
yes but they're just not close to home
so what what would happen is that
why does home matter
you make 17 an hour in a part-time job
move
i i live at home with my parents
oh okay that does matter then yeah good
answer okay
so you're 24
i'm 21. 21. okay
yeah well let me dave you weigh in here
but i think the first thing that you've
got to do is you've got to get a 20 an
hour job 25 an hour job right now
companies are begging people that have a
pulse and some good character and the
ability to show up on time and i think
you've got to be paying attention to
what's out there and it ain't part-time
it's full-time because you're living
with money 80 hours a week yeah you're
going crazy to save up 14 000 a year but
you've got this debt you got to deal
with too but
listen you can do this
i think you save up and pay cash for it
but i want you to do two or three things
okay i'm with ken you've got to get your
hours up and you got to get better jobs
and you you you really need to be
working about 80 hours a week
you don't need to see you don't need to
you're you don't need any social life if
you want to do this you got to set some
stuff aside no partying you're gonna
have to go for it
okay now if you got if you know the
second thing is i want you to shop
get the details from the people not
google
i want you to find three
different
schools
that will give you this certification
get the best deal
you can get from all three schools
now
let's pretend
that the school that you that you just
gave us it as 28 000 off of 40 means you
need 12. does that sound right
yeah yeah okay
you only need 12 000 to go to that
school
that's not much
because now you're working 80 hours a
week
and the plan we're giving you okay so
you're going to go work 80 hours a week
you're going to get 12 000 together now
if that's and that's your dream
school correct
correct yeah that's my dream career no
let's not say career i said school that
particular school that is the one you
have selected that you would like to go
to because it's close to home right
yeah it's i wouldn't say it's my dream
school it's my only option no no no no
no no no it's not your only option your
only option if you live at home
if you go to upstate new york and they
pay you to go there
and you're going free and they give you
ten thousand dollars to live you can go
up there
it's not your only option it's the only
option you have found so far but you
haven't done much shopping yet that's
correct you're buying a 40 000 item you
need to do some better shopping
and get more bids now here's what i want
you to do i want you to find the other
school
that will give you uh not 28 000 in
scholarships but will give you
where you need 12 out of pocket i want
you to let's say that you only need six
out of pocket at this other school and
then i want you to go back to the first
school and say hey
these guys
are trying to get me to go over here
and they're offering me
everything but six thousand if you want
me to come you're going to have to match
that
little negotiation there
this phone call just made you thousands
of dollars
if you follow what we taught you yeah
okay
so number one lots of hours and better
jobs i'm serious as a heart attack about
working 80 hours a week i want you to be
exhausted but i want you to have 20 000
cash in the bank before you know it to
ready to do this okay
number two okay three
detailed bids from the three different
schools of exactly what they will offer
you and then play them against each
other in a negotiation technique to get
the best deal working for you okay
okay number three
the failed premise in this whole
discussion at the beginning of it was
that somehow this is going to be a magic
wand and your life is all going to be
okay because you're a
attack at the end of this an ultrasound
tech wrong answer
where you go to school what you learn is
almost never the secret sauce
you
are the secret sauce your character your
ability to kick doors down and make
stuff happen
you
are what makes you successful not a
degree
not a certain school that you go to
there is no correlation in any piece of
research on the planet based on where
you go to school and whether you're
successful or not
but there is a correlation between
character qualities and who's successful
the perseverance
fight hutzpah
poise
confidence integrity
these are the things that make people
successful not degrees
and not a certain stinking school
it once you're once you're a ultrasound
tech they don't even care where you got
that from
all they care is you got certification
now we can hire you
and i've had ultrasounds and i've gone
in for mris and i've gone in for this i
never once asked the tech where they
went to school
oh wait a minute i can't i can't you
went to that school i can't let you do
the mri i can't let you do those you
know never once did i stop them from
running an ultrasound on my wife with
one of our babies
because of where they went to school
that's absolute trash and bs
most people don't know where their
lawyer went to school they don't know
where their doctor went to school they
don't know where their real estate agent
went to school
where you went to school is the biggest
joke on the planet
it's the most overrated bunch of crap
and it's destroyed
the dadgum higher education world
you just wait all this new documentary
borrowed future comes out in october
it's going to blow your all's minds
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today number one best-selling
author and author of the book
that is just released in pre-sale
pre-order is available pay from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing work
you love you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com right now
for twenty dollars and you get almost
200 worth of goodies with it uh goodies
being stuff like the ebook the audiobook
um
take it to the live stream there is all
kinds of things happening there so check
it all out from paycheck to purpose
we will actually ship these books in
november on the actual pub date but a
pre-sale is where you get the best
possible deal
and christy's new book comes out
next week and so you've just got a few
days to get take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance uh
yeah and all the goodies with it on
pre-sale uh just a few days to take
advantage of that so you ought to
probably pick them both up while you're
there at ramsey solutions dot com chris
is with us in santa rosa california hi
kurt whoa wait a minute try that again
chris there you are hey what's up
hey dave and ken uh thanks for taking
the call sure how can we help you
well before i get into it i have
listened to borrowed future and that is
just really
wonderful first class well thank you
but anyways so um i'm
coming into my golden years and i
watched my dad play golf for 25 years
and i don't want to do that
okay
so what i want to do is
kind of go into
building families i have a mission
statement here build and equip family
teams
to produce successful 30 year olds
and
so mostly for ken i got that's my
getting clear
qualified i spent about 25 years with my
wife raising our kids at homeschooling
and they've all graduated from college
and are
well married and employed and everything
step 3 get connected
i'm kind of there and i'm kind of on to
get started and that's the main thing i
want to talk about is getting started
so
i've got some outline for some training
programs
but i want to kind of brainstorm and say
should i do that like webinars podcasts
seminars stuff like that oh yeah that's
my question yeah all of the above yeah
because you don't know what's
necessarily going to stick we try
everything around here
and uh sometimes we're surprised by what
doesn't work and sometimes we're
surprised by what does work and
sometimes we're not surprised at all
but we we try it all i mean we've got
youtube channels and podcasts and radio
shows and books and live events and
digital classrooms and in person
classrooms and coaches and so we're
we've got a whole bunch of different
ways to help you with your life
transformation and training and you
probably i mean you don't have you can't
launch them all at one time it's too
much but uh there's no reason not to try
over a period of time a bunch of
different things yeah and chris what i
would tell you to do is just come up
with a basic methodology keep it super
super simple you know dave dave
challenged me on this several years ago
and all of the ramsey personalities and
if you can come up with a very clear
path
okay so if you were sitting down with a
couple right now and they've got five
and six and seven-year-olds and they
said how'd you do it how'd you and your
wife do it well how would you tell them
uh what they need to do that you know
that you all did and you know that it
worked keep it really simple and begin
to come up with a simple methodology
that's where i would start before you
start podcasting and webinars and things
come up with what your clear path is and
then begin to test that because that
will change the way you say it what you
add to it all of that will happen and
i'm curious to know if you're involved
in a church by any chance
yeah and actually we're
transitioning from one part of the
country to another to be close to
grandkids so we're kind of right
uh
we're where we're moving to is uh
a good church with a pretty large
homeschool contingent great
great is this gonna be a side hustle
he's retired oh you've retired
well i have a
like a handyman sort of business so it's
kind of i can
monitor moderate one and build the other
one up at the same time perfect well go
really slow uh what i was asking about
the church uh is as you begin to get
into community there where you've got
this built-in demographic you know
parents or is your demographic with
younger kids and if you can get an
opportunity to volunteer your time
to maybe teach a class at a church
that is a great way to test this
material out and test it out without any
pressure and then the other temptation
is is to you know pour a lot of money in
it feeling like well i can pour some gas
on the fire when there is actually no
flame so really test it test it test it
work on it and then slowly begin to put
it out a podcast is a great way to do it
or even a youtube channel because again
your barrier for entry is almost
non-existent this is hardly anything you
got to do there the principles in your
material won't change the processes that
you use will change
and they will polish and they will
update and so yeah spending a ton of
money on your uh first round of product
is a bad idea because a lot of it's
gonna end up in the trash
and uh your prototype so to speak you
know here's an example when we started
the baby steps the first baby step was
not a thousand dollars
it was get out of debt
and then we kept running into
people's tire would blow out and they
didn't have the money to fix their tire
and so they quit the whole stinking
program
and so we figured out putting a thousand
dollar a little bit of a pad on the
front end
was the um
answer to uh you know fixing the baby
steps making them work so it iterated
but if i had uh 25 000 worth of stuff
with the wrong baby steps on it it would
have all gone in the dumpster
you know and so you're going to change
what you do now the principle didn't
change the principle save money get out
of debt live on less than you make
you know live on a budget be generous
these are the principles we teach from
scripture
on money but
how you implement that is the process
and how we teach you to implement it is
the process and it has evolved
over the 30 years that we have done this
and that's what's going to happen yeah
well i mean hey just another personal
example uh
he called in and he was repeating the
seven stages well you know this and our
leadership knows that's something what i
came up with four years ago i was really
trying to figure out how to create a
very simple uh and explainable process
clear path for people and it wasn't that
now let's get clear get qualified get
connected get started that didn't exist
for about three and a half years and it
was just constantly trying to listen to
the audience as you coach and as you
talk to the people and share the message
you want to share you're right the
polishing is what's beautiful about that
but that's the activity gotta stay
active gotta stay really really busy and
delivering that content yeah i think uh
chris you could probably go at this a
little bit like i did a long time ago
i had a a little small office and did
some one-on-one coaching yep
and i taught a few little classes here
or there and i taught a sunday school
class and the financial peace university
materials
some of what we teach to this day in fpu
was in that original sunday school class
not all of it but some of it
and it was just a place to
interact with the user you know of the
material changes everything
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five we wanna hear from you guys
that are listeners of the ramsey show
we're doing a survey of you right now we
wanna know what's going on and one of
the things we're asking is how much debt
you paid off so far we've heard of
almost 241 million dollars in debt from
just the people that have taken the
survey
not bad at all so if you'd like to take
the survey you'll be in a drawing for an
amazon gift card 250 dollars
not bad at all not bad at all a lot of
not bad at all's going on here check it
out text survey to 33 789 tell us what
you think about this show text survey to
33789 or visit ramseysolutions.com
survey
open phones at
825-5225
jerry is with us jerry is in mobile
alabama hi jerry how are you
hey i'm so great thank you for uh for
putting me on absolutely how can we help
yeah so i have a small based home based
business and i teach blacksmithing and
knife making
just here outside mobile alabama um as
i've been getting to grow i actually
just pulled the trigger on doing this
full time and so now i'm wanting to open
up a
permanent location a little bit closer
to the beach area uh to help kind of
take advantage of the seven million
tours that we have that come each year
to visit the lower alabama area i found
a building that has a great layout a
great location i've been negotiating
back and forth with the leasing agent
for the contract terms
but i propose a early termination clause
just in the event in case my business
fails however he came back and said no
he will not put in an early termination
clause and even with the penalty and he
wants a five-year lease but he's also
open to subleasing in case the business
fails i lost a business in 2008 which
led to a bankrupt scene so i really kind
of changed my perspective and i'm just
trying to see if this is a wise
agreement to enter into but my wife
feels like this is going into debt so
she said why don't you call mr ramsey
and see what he says okay
well i don't consider that going into
debt it is a contractual obligation
obviously
um and so it does feel like that but uh
we've signed leases uh here in the in
the days before we owned the real estate
that we're in and
um
we just want to be super conservative
about that and this sounds like it's a
little over the edge of conservative
given that your business is not even
running
operating full time yet
um and we're jumping into a five-year
lease if you'd been running it at least
for a year
i'd feel a whole lot better about it ken
your thoughts yeah
this is one of those things jerry where
you're really excited and and by the way
congratulations on doing this i love
this is craftsmanship i love this
business and you've been doing well
enough to where you're saying okay now
i'm doing it full time i want you to do
what is very hard for human beings to do
and i struggle with this as much as
anybody and that is be patient
there are other buildings
there there is another season by which
you'll be able to get in that location
that's closer to the beach that would be
able to take advantage of the tourism
this temptation to move now comes from
i gotta strike while the iron is hot and
and the reality is it's not hot enough
uh i think you know
yeah
that's right that's right i'm not trying
to do that but you did it anyway you
fell right into it you did it it's
really true it's amazing how that
happens i've heard legendary stories of
dave doing it anyway here's the thing
jerry be patient
let's get this business
really stable
moving from part-time to full-time is a
big
big jump so let's prove to ourselves
that we can actually keep this thing
going keep expenses really really low
build this thing build this thing be
patient be patient the the line i want
to stick in your head jerry if i can i'm
a big braveheart uh fanny have you ever
seen the movie braveheart jerry
it's been a while it's been a while you
remember that scene where there's the
big battle and and uh william wallace
picks the fight in the in the the
infantry excuse me the cavalry uh is
coming at him and they got the long
sticks and he's saying hold
hold hold that's your theme right now
and there's gonna be a season yeah but
listen that's where you at i think that
is where you've got to be just be
patient right now the time
to do this will be so abundantly clear
that you won't have to call the ramsay
show to say
what do you think i think it'll be
really obvious three three things that
came to mind while ken was talking
number one
i do not move forward on large business
deals where sharon is uncomfortable
every time i go against my wife's
feeling
i have a bad feeling about this i make a
mistake you're about to make a mistake
number two
the best in 30 plus years of doing
business the best business decisions i
have made
bar none were the deals i decided not to
do
the ones i look back that i walked away
from that and i go oh thank god and i
walked away from that and i go oh thank
god what if i had done that where would
we be today oh man
and uh and so on and so the deals i've
walked away from and then the last thing
is this
uh you have uh one option
and so you have no negotiating power
whatsoever and no emotional
margin for negotiating because you only
have one option you've fallen in love
with this one place i want you to go
find three other places that you can do
this you'll probably find one you can
prop up for a one year lease i would do
it one year
and your wife would do it one year and
it's three doors down from the thing
you're looking at
and it's kind of like going
in and you know but i'm kid i don't know
i mean
it might be a little smaller it might
not be the perfect thing but it's your
it's your it's your version one
and maybe this bigger deal is your is
your version two or version three later
and go get in that same general
neighborhood and take advantage of those
same the the the the not take advantage
in a negative way but i mean to be in a
position to serve those tourists that
you're wanting to serve but in a
different location than that particular
piece of property
i always know when i feel pressured to
something and it's like a problem and
it's like a hesitation and
you called us so you kind of got that
that's like i really want to do this i'm
excited about it but it feels like it's
a stretch feels like it's over the top
when i start feeling that it usually
means i don't have enough options
when i put three or four more options on
the table options are power
when it comes to negotiation options are
power when it comes to decision making
you'll make better decisions when you
have three or four valid ways you can do
this but always there'll be a you know
one's better than twos better than three
better than four you'll be able to
prioritize which one's better but you've
got i can do it in one of those three
areas yeah so and that changes the whole
picture yeah one of the things i found
dave i know in my journey is that this
idea of kicking the door down has been
romanticized in hollywood movies and on
some really bad
success type motivational posters but
the reality is is that rarely happens
you know this idea if you've got to kick
a door down
uh it's rare that i've had to kick a
door down but i've had some i've walked
through some doors that swung wide open
and timing
um is really really important and i
think sometimes when we've got a dream
not sometimes when we have a dream
that we deeply long for uh we can get
kind of sucked into this
let's go now and yeah and because of the
passion behind it we love it i mean he's
a craftsman he loves the trade and
everybody listening could tell that you
and i are both excited about his
business oh yeah i love it hey great
idea i buy a knife from them and by the
way if you've never seen a blacksmith do
their thing if you've never been to one
of those historical homes it really is a
lost trade and it's a wonderful
wonderful thing and people are embracing
that kind of stuff so you know the key
here is is is don't try to force it yup
you won't have to when the time is right
you won't have to force it i i just
found that successful men and women yes
they push hard yes they work hard they
don't give up but this idea of kicking
doors down and bowling things over
that's that's a little that's that's
been mystified and hollywoodized i don't
think it's necessary to get you in big
trouble but if you're patient
uh the right door will open yeah
so
i'm not doing that deal no don't do that
deal that deal is too long his wife's
uncomfortable with it
he's really uncomfortable he is too he's
he's less uncomfortable than she is but
you don't i don't go against my spouse
yep the peace that passes understanding
that's it you need that peace to move
forward on the big deal and you know
what he's a pull of dave ramsey this is
what i've learned from dave maybe tell
that guy i'm walking but i will tell you
what i will do i'll do a year lease
other than that thanks but no
yeah you what do you got to lose when
you wouldn't give me my termination
clause you lost me
that's it and walk on your heel baby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage sean and mary are with
us hey guys hey how you doing welcome
welcome where do you guys live
sacramento california all right welcome
to nashville and all the way here to do
a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off we paid off 255 000.
i love it and how long did this take you
too long four years
four years it's always too long i agree
and your range of income during that
time uh we started about 140 000 and we
had a couple good years in sales and
bumped up over 200. oh yeah good what do
you guys do for a living uh vice
president of sales for a tech company
okay
i
handle the five monkeys off the set
right now
i am the ring leader i am the ring
master
i love it all right
255 000 in four years what kind of debt
was this it was our mortgage you paid
off your ass
you're weird we did it i love it in
sacramento freaking california too i
mean this is not a cheap real estate
market it's been good to us it's a paid
off house wow
what's this house worth well you know
it's been a good year so i guess now
about 600 but it depends on the day i
guess it might be 650 tomorrow in
california
very cool good for you guys man and
you're young how old are you two i'm 36.
i'm a smidge older but okay we don't
need to know yeah we're moving on
36 plus a smidge
there we go now we have we have the
algebra formula now figure it out so
way to go guys
man that's impressive so what started
you on this journey four years ago well
it probably goes back further in 2009 we
got married we have some good friends
that gave us the total money makeover
when we got married
and i was getting my mba in finance and
i said you know i know all this stuff i
don't need i don't do this but i read it
and i thought it was interesting and
then i started doing it by myself and i
we got through all our consumer debt but
i was really doing it by myself it took
us
four years just to get through that and
because we weren't really working
together
um and then we moved i don't teach that
in the mba no they don't no they don't
then we moved to california and mary
wanted to buy a house and i said well
how about if we do financial peace
university together then we can buy a
house oh
and i said
okay what harm it's just a class i'll
just i'll watch some videos yeah and you
get me that house that's great that's a
good that's a good trade
okay what's the worst thing that could
happen oh god four years
it escalated really quickly
that's awesome but then she loved us so
much we started teaching the class oh
wow that's what really kicked us into
gear for the house that's serious then
yeah
thank you guys so proud of you thank you
well done how many classes have you
taught oh we taught three well thank you
it's like a built-in date night you know
yeah if you go i gotta go coordinate we
gotta go yeah well i mean yeah you got
five kids
any excuse yeah we're in the area we
love them but it's we love them at home
that's right good job well done man you
got no house payment it's amazing how
does it feel
it's that's pretty incredible we've had
to we paid it off in july so we've had
this is our second month of not having a
mortgage payment it's been uh we were
able to come out here so our first uh
first big thing we promised the kids to
come out to nashville so here we are
that's fun that's true way to go yeah so
you got to we got a young couple here
and this is because you guys are
definitely young let me just say that
all right uh and and i'm just curious
how the conversation changes
you're because you're you're moving
towards paying this house off you get
there now you're two months post paying
this baby off how are the conversations
changing around money and what you're
dreaming about what are you looking
forward to i said this before we left i
said you know we've been pushing so long
towards getting the house paid off and
we did our last
you know big payment to finish it i said
i kind of feel poor for the first time
in a while because we've sent all this
money out the door and now i don't
really want to
go you know spending a lot on things but
there are things we've been waiting to
do
but should we do them now i don't know
so it's the letting go of that of the
intensity which four years it's not
gazelle but it's not too slow either oh
that's pretty that's shifting
yeah shifting gears has been a little
yeah i think the key there is i mean we
we've been very intentional with
not doing certain projects on the house
or not doing big vacations just doing
little ones during the house payoff
and now we get to do some fun stuff but
we're also we want to make sure we do
the right things and spend the money in
the right places so we're wise later but
have some fun with it yeah way to go way
to go i'm so proud of y'all thank you
what a quite a killer hero couple you
guys are just heroes
so well done
very very fun what now you're teaching
the class
you're baby step seven
i mean you're there
uh
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you're actually
experts
i think that's to you i don't know gosh
you really can't do it unless you're
doing it together and
i love that we've watched both the the
financial piece the original set and
then the new set we did that two years
ago
we like to be nerds and compare the
differences in your little monologues
we kind of prefer though at the first
set to the new set in just a couple
places we like when you throw the barbie
over the shoulder yeah yeah
they like vintage dave
revenge but there's some stuff in there
that'll get you put in jail
only in california yeah throw barbie
over your shoulder that's just like gosh
what kind of what kind of mania what
kind of kind of
male sexist pig are you
our favorite kind
so barking together i'd say the other
key is the budget so we at the at the
beginning i mentioned i was doing it by
myself with um at with our consumer debt
and i did spreadsheets galore i'm the
nerd and i would have all sorts of
spreadsheets and i'd sit her down and
i'd say look at all these great
spreadsheets i'm an mba look at this
blind just like numbs up and say i'd be
like on a stool next to the computer and
he's in the computer like the the desk
chair with the mouse and the things yeah
he's like captain kirk and then you're
like off to the side yes i was like
waiting for it to be over yeah but when
we but
when every dollar came out
when every dollar came out that was the
key every day
and we were able to
see everything together and it was it
was it was not a spreadsheet but it
still was able to keep us on track of
what was happening and do our
transactions together it was uh it was
complicated enough but not too much yeah
that's what it's supposed to be yeah
well done all right so you've been doing
the retirement savings all along yes we
have how much is in the 401ks and roth
iras so last week uh when the stock
market went up we were at just over a
million so whoa we are uh with the house
with the house so oh so your baby steps
we just hit a million last week so we're
basically baby steps millionaires and
baby steven and and you're not even uh
36 in a smidge i mean my gosh
wow
that's impressive it is i mean wow we're
talking about major major money and
impact that's that's in your future yeah
600 000 paid for house and over a half
million dollars in yeah in investments
is what we're saying and if you you know
go back 12 years as you say anything you
do for long enough you do it the right
way 12 years from when we first started
in 2009 and we built it up and now we're
here we are yeah it really works like a
case study right out of us right out of
the survey yeah right
well done well done
and um you brought the kiddos we sure
did five of them we might have left one
in
omaha i don't know if it made the trip
there's a home alone somewhere
oh or in the airport or something in
there in a locker
yeah all right so they uh
those of you at home uh his t-shirt says
baby her
uh uh mary's t-shirt says step and then
the kids spell out what letters on
theirs that say seven yeah yeah
s-e-v-e-n so all right it's all right we
got it i love it baby step seven they're
there and they're not even 40 years old
wow very very very cool all right the
kiddos names and ages all right we have
joseph here who is 11.
uh we'll go over here i guess ambrose is
nine
mary augusta is six and uh steven here
is five and little baby will be one next
month all right little baby good stuff
[Laughter]
that's fun you guys are amazing we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is your next chapter in your story
though you completely changed the legacy
of all of these kiddos i'm so proud of
y'all you're such a neat couple well
done well done you deserve every bit of
the success and all the hard work you've
poured into this your proof it can be
done in america today absolutely amazing
all right shawn and mary and the tribe
from sacramento house and everything 255
000 paid off in four years making 140 to
200. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're
[Music]
[Applause]
i
love it how fun
man that's powerful
the number of people that are doing
their debts free scream and
simultaneously becoming baby steps
millionaires are counting up
it's happening more and more
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show author of
the number one bestseller the proximity
principle and the new book that will
also be a number one comes out in
november and it's on pre-sale now it's
called from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
all right we're gonna spend a lot of our
lives at work we should be doing
something we love and we should be doing
something that's profitable
simultaneously and they're not mutually
exclusive you don't have to be broke to
be happy that's a mythology thing that
floats around actually ken addresses
that so you can pre-order the book at
ramseysolutions.com and right now while
it's in pre-order you get about a
hundred dollars worth of uh extras with
it quite a nice bundle
when you order the book for 20 in
pre-sale beverly is with us beverly's in
boise idaho hi beverly how are you
hi dave
hi hi ken thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
i have a very simple question for you
how much cash is
too much cash to keep at home
and where would you put it where should
you put it since the banks are only
giving you one percent
so you're a uh
cash under the mattress woman are you
uh
maybe it's some coffee cans buried in
the backyard
[Laughter]
so how much cash do you want to keep at
home
well you always say have cash for stuff
well obviously you cannot go down to the
car store and put seventy thousand
dollars of cash on their debt
so you cannot go down to the what store
the automobile store and put seventy
thousand dollars cash did you say
seventy
yeah you're buying a nice car
to buy a new car to buy a truck you're
buying a nice truck
all right well i i don't do that when
i'm buying a 70 000 item i wire it
i i don't carry cash in now if i'm
negotiating with an individual for a
used item i might use the power of cash
like we have taught and wave it under
their nose and see if i can get a better
deal i've done that i'm not above doing
that
but i don't i um
i don't i don't think i'm gonna
recommend beverly walks down with a
suitcase full of money like a drug
dealer to a 70 000 car purchase i'm just
going to let you wire that money in
so you would put the money in the bank
and wire it and get one percent well
you're not getting anything in the
bottom of your mattress
true yeah
so it's it's you know i know that it's
not the one
it's i don't want you to get robbed i
don't want somebody knock you in the
head and take 70 grand out of your house
i don't have 70 grand in my house
so that's just when you say you pay cash
for stuff you keep your money in a bank
or a credit union or something and then
you wire it yeah and i wire it and
meaning i don't go into debt is what i
mean when i pay cash now i have a pocket
full of cash right now i i carry a uh
you know a money clip in my front pocket
that's usually got a thousand bucks in
it but that just because i like how i'm
a redneck i like having some money in my
pocket right you know but that's just
walking around money and if i want to
buy something or you know most of what
that wallet goes for is tips
for you know when i park a car or when
i'm uh finish up playing a game of golf
and a guy cleans my clubs you know that
kind of stuff when i come over and mow
your lawn yeah when ken comes over and
washes dishes for us we give him a
little tip and by the way i want to
point out don't don't come to some live
event and try to take money off of dave
because he's also got something else in
his in his back pocket
i just i just think i should point that
out that could be a bad scenario for
something i'm trying to take you know
i'm not gonna get robbed it's okay
that's okay nobody wants to rob me
but the uh i'm not really muggable i'm
just huggable but the uh uh
yeah
but anyway the uh uh yeah i don't walk
around with a bunch of cash in that
regard by when i say cash is king at the
beginning of the show it doesn't mean
that jesus isn't king
it means the the cat that cash has power
and paying for things rather than going
into debt to get them is power and so um
you know i know a few people that keep
five or ten thousand dollars cash in a
little safe in their house just in case
they you know wanted to grab a hold of a
little money for some reason or another
on a short notice and the atm was jammed
up or something then that's okay but i
you know i i don't believe in keeping
50 100 200 000
uh you're starting to get into the land
of preppers and stuff like that then and
i'm i'm not i'm not that guy and i don't
recommend that so interesting discussion
though beverly i
i have a lot of curiosity about what's
going on at your house at this point i
gotta tell you dave i part of you would
love to see beverly walk in with some
armed security with a suitcase and plop
it up on the counter and i'd like that
truck right over there
i bet you could get a discount i'll
guarantee you she can get a discount
she's awesome gavin is with us gavin's
in chicago hey gavin what's up
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
i wanted to ask you a question can i
afford to go to hawaii with my wife for
a friend's wedding
what do you have the money
i i think we do she's worried we've
never spent this much money
um do you have the money in cash without
going into debt to do it is what i'm
asking oh that's absolutely yeah we're
at four five six okay
you're in baby steps four five and six
and how much is the trip
yeah we're thinking like seven grand
yeah sounds about right
and you've got that money and what do
you guys make a year
we make about 180 000 a year why could
you not afford this
because we're so cheap
now the truth comes out
it has nothing to do with the arithmetic
it's the emotional state
yeah i mean we're trying we're trying to
pay off trying to pay off our houses
yeah and
and and you know live like no one else
and yeah
how old are you guys
i'm 39. you ever been to you ever been
to hawaii
i have on a company trip so i never paid
for it has she been
yes she has she has she says she has no
desire but we we haven't been to kauai
yet we've been to the big island and not
quite okay but you're not just gonna fly
over for the wedding and then bolt as
soon as the reception's over correct oh
no no that's all yeah that's a that's a
12-hour flight we're gonna go for a week
hold on there you go my point is that's
the difference
yeah you guys gotta talk about this as
an awesome opportunity to get away and
reward each other for this sacrifice you
make really good money you're out of
debt except you're home you're executing
a financial plan four five six
um you should go
yeah thank you you should do this you
should do well guess what she said if
you said yes then we get to go okay
i'm not i'm i'm not making the decision
but i'm just saying
the arithmetic is that you you are not
being irresponsible
okay
and when you said we're just cheap and
you laughed you were sort of kidding but
not really
and so the thing you guys want to be
careful of
there are three things you can do with
money you can invest it you can be
generous with it and you can enjoy it
almost everyone is weak in one of them
and so watch the one that you're weak in
and you're the one you guys are weak in
is you're not you're not good at
enjoying your money
right and you need to you know i mean we
have a we have a million dollars in our
nest egg yeah so you need to so you're
really good at investing how's your
generosity probably medium
minimal yeah i'll see
yeah the truth is there's usually a
correlation between uh the the people
who enjoy their money and the generosity
so one of the things we do at our house
and this might help you
is um you kind of feel like you're doing
something wrong if you're doing
something opulent like a week long in
hawaii that's a big time expenditure
right so one of the things we do is
sometimes we'll just increase our
generosity by the same amount we spend
on ourselves
okay and we just like uh okay god who
can we who do you want to help today uh
i want to give seven thousand dollars to
uh i wanna buy two single moms a three
thousand dollar car this week show me
lead them to me lord and and then i'll
go do that and and then i'll go to
hawaii and i don't think about it yeah
gotcha sometimes the generosity muscle
works almost simultaneously with the
enjoyment muscle take some extra cash to
hawaii and bless somebody out of their
mind who's serving you take 70 000 and
buy you a truck while you're there
call beverly pick her up on the way
drop a truck off of boise on your way
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is your show
america thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here to talk to you about
your careers your jobs
doing work that you love the clear path
to doing work you love from his new book
from paycheck to purpose
available on pre-sale right now at
ramseysolutions.com herbert is going to
be up first this hour he's in guatemala
hi herbert how are you
hi david how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
here's listen here's the thing i'm
30 years old i'm from guatemala i just
got engaged with a beautiful lady she's
28. congratulations please
thank you thank you we're both dead
three engineers i'm a sales manager and
she's a finance manager
right now i have around
200 grand in savings and she has around
50k
so each year we make around 160 it's 80
each okay
so um we will marry next year and we
were wondering if we should rent for
maybe four or five years
and invest that the money we make in
that time to pay cars for our house
what will a house cost
maybe around
400 grand
500 grand
you can't buy one for 250.
yes we can the thing is that we were
thinking about buying
like a house that will we will be there
forever and you i know what i mean
there's very few people stay in the
house forever
okay
the forever house thing now are you
talking about in guatemala or talking
about in the states
yeah in guatemala
okay i do not know anything at all about
guatemala real estate not a thing okay
okay can't i most people here stay at
their home like for life yeah
okay
is the average home in america in the
u.s sells every 5.6 years
okay so uh this when people in america
say it's a forever home i laugh at them
because it's because it's not true okay
now it might be it might be more
culturally true there
okay the second thing i don't know is i
don't know if you bought a 250 000 home
now and paid cash for it
meanwhile you have no rent because you
have a paid for home
you could save that much more you'd be
able to save more because you don't have
any rent cost
could how hard would it be to sell the
250 000 home when you saved up another
200 000 to move up to the half million
dollar house
is the market is the market viable can
you sell something fairly easily
yeah yeah you can do that okay so if you
moved in a house for 250 000 and lived
there three years and during that time
you saved up another 300 000 and then
you sold that house for 300 000 you'd
have 600 000 right
yeah
meanwhile you had no rent
yeah that's right
that works if the real estate market is
viable enough
that you feel sure you can sell this
starter house
when you want to move up
but if it's very very difficult to sell
a house then maybe this suggestion is
not a good idea
okay
and should we invest that money during
that time
yes yeah absolutely um into something
and again you've got to choose a vehicle
that
fits your situation um and i and i'm not
an expert on what's available to you for
all of that
so
you know that that that's the the thing
um i'm i'm nervous you can tell i'm
stammering around with my verbiage
because i just don't know that your your
cultural norms number one well enough i
mean i have a vague understanding but
well enough and i certainly don't know
the real estate market well enough to
where i can say this is what you ought
to do
so you've kind of got to use some
judgment with the knowledge you have of
uh the world you live in which is
different uh in some respects
and so you got to make those calls
interesting discussion though it is i
would just caution you know just because
everybody else does it or a majority of
people buy one house and stay in that
house in guatemala it doesn't mean that
you have to do that i mean it could
certainly be a cultural norm but what do
you two want as a young couple and i
gotta tell you i don't care if you're
from guatemala uh or the united states
or anywhere else in the world a young
couple
life is so very different in those first
couple of years and as you begin to move
through the phases of life whatever
that's going to look like for you guys
things are going to change dramatically
so having this mindset that we've got to
come out of the gate and buy our forever
house
i just think it in some ways can lock
your dreams and lock your future up a
little bit so i would just caution that
just because everybody else does it
doesn't mean it's the right thing for
you yeah hey good call thank you for
joining us mary's with us mary's in san
jose california hi mary welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave
so my situation is i'm 58 years old i
lost my job last year so i decided to
take early retirement
i'm living off a passive income of my
rental
i have no consumer debt but i still have
a mortgage payment i refi last year so i
get the 1.99
so
about a month ago i
i found out about your principle and so
now i'm so fired up to pay off my
my mortgage cool so
yes and so shall i start collecting my
pension
see the thing is the reason why i
postponed it was if i collect now i will
get only 4 600 a month
if i wait until i'm 62 it's going to be
5 500 a month
and if i wait until 65 it's gonna be six
thousand dollars a month so what do i do
do you have a lump sum option
no unfortunately not okay
all right
um
well
obviously the pension dies with you
right
i'm sorry yes of course and so um
the money you collect between now and
the time that it would go up
if we ran the math figures on just for
the fun of it it's not what we're going
to do
but you said you said it goes up at 62
to 5 500 16. that's 60 in two years it's
going to be 55 yeah okay all right but
you have two years no actually it's four
because i'm 58 now so at 62 it will go
up to 5500. okay so four times four
times five yeah four times 12 is 48
months of collecting 4 500
that pile of money invested would likely
make you more than the other thousand
that they're going to give you for
waiting
does that make sense to you
yeah i'm taking it i'm not going to do
that with it i'm going to take it now
and pay off your house
but that that tells you that you
probably ought to take as quick as you
can take it
and um
because the more you get the more years
you're getting money i understand the
monthly changes on it and the other
thing is you're probably going to do
some kind of encore career you're
probably not done at 58. you've probably
got some other stuff you're supposed to
do yet
you don't have to
but it'd be cool if you wouldn't made
another 80 grand a year just doing
something you love absolutely
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five how many of you guys
are stressed out or you're hurting
because your retirement savings
got you scared
maybe you were super close to retiring
and um now you're wondering if you
should work longer well you need a
someone in your corner that will walk
you through
the process of emotionally surviving
the ups and downs of the investing world
and that way you don't jump in and jump
out at exactly the wrong times which is
what most people do so you need the data
tells us that the people that have a
uh
an investing professional in their
corner
with the heart of a teacher
uh actually end up making more money
through the scope of their life mainly
because they stay invested it's that
simple so you can restore your
confidence go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester check in with one of our
smart vester pros have them get in your
corner and help you out our question
today comes from blinds.com they have a
100 satisfaction guarantee that means
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from rhonda in
florida my husband has served in
children's ministry leadership for over
30 years our church recently went
through some financial difficulties and
the pastor asked if any staff would be
willing to step down my husband decided
to opt out and was given one month
severance prior to working at the church
he had started working on his
associate's degree and now has gone back
to get his aaa and business
administration at age 57 is it worth
finishing up this aaa is there a field
for someone with 24 years of
experiencing experience rather in
managing a large ministry let's take
that first excuse me the second question
first
there's absolutely a field for someone
with 24 years of experience in managing
a large ministry because that is a
leadership position and there is always
a need for leadership in
the workforce certainly in corporate
america and so what has to happen is
it's less about the ministry
specifications but more about the
leadership experience as far as the
first question uh if the if the aaa in
business administration helps add a
little bit of juice to his resume and
gets him a little bit more on the resume
besides the ministry experience and you
can afford it and it's not uh in any way
causing you guys a struggle financially
yes i'd go ahead and finish it
and uh the reality is is that this is
where relationships come into play dave
you know you've got somebody who's been
in one industry for so long 24 years and
then you're looking to switch gears into
another industry the transferable
experience is what it's all about but it
is more about the relationships you have
that will open up doors think of all the
people that your husband knows through
those years of ministry and living in
this community
right now this is the hottest hiring
market we've ever seen even hotter than
pre-covered
of february of 2020 10.4 million jobs
the latest job report
um and companies need
good experience and good leadership and
at 57 though you will face
this is just the reality you will face
some people kind of looking at his
resume or look at him going oh he's 57.
and so this is where relationships come
in people that you know that know other
people and those doors get open that way
to where you're coming in already ahead
of the competition because of the
credibility
of the relationship to say i know this
guy great leader a lot of experience got
the talent to be able to come in and
help us that's how you win this game
my mind as a salesman always goes to how
does he sell himself yes uh what's the
narrative
and um that he brings to the company
that he's interviewing with
and uh so and the product is him yes and
he has to sell that product it's a
little uncomfortable a little awkward to
sell yourself but here's the thing
if for 30 years
you can survive
the parents
while you run a children's ministry
you have people skills oh yeah yeah and
think about how many volunteers you know
how to herd cats yes oh my gosh
that's right unbelievable yeah and
church leaders almost always even in the
large churches with large staffs almost
always rely on volunteer help and if i'm
a if i'm a hiring manager or a leader
looking to hire another leader i would
lead with
hey i've effectively led volunteers
people who don't have to show up yeah i
get people who to care i get people who
work because they care yes not because
they're being paid and uh and i've
managed all of these relationships
around all these kids
parents uh helicoptering in and
everything else for all these years and
i think you build a narrative around
that
[Music]
and and uh uh otherwise if you don't if
you don't position yourself in someone's
mind they may say oh you've been a
babysitter yes
yeah you've been a babysitter for 30
years yeah and that's not what this guy
did that's exactly right that's a great
point if you don't position yourself
well guess what they will position
they're going to position you somewhere
yeah in their head yeah they're going to
pigeonhole you because we try to go okay
what's that mean what's this guy do
what's it how does that fit what i need
how can you do that and if you don't go
listen i know how to lead volunteers i
know how to deal with difficult
relationships highly emotional
situations yeah i mean this guy could
run a customer care center easy where
there's complaints coming in that's
exactly right because that's what he's
been doing yeah and and to your point if
you're applying for leadership positions
look at the job description and then fit
your experience into that and go hey
you're looking for this this is how i
did this this and this yeah i can add
value for you guys and i i did it before
yeah in a different setting but a very
similar transactional process
julie is with us julie is in tampa
florida hi julie welcome to the ramsay
show
hi guys how are you doing better than we
deserve what's up
awesome uh so so yeah my name is julie
i am 24 years old married my husband and
i both work full-time
he's also a full-time paramedic student
um so my question is i am i'm at risk of
losing my job by thanksgiving they are
requiring a coveted vaccine for
in-person work by them and my husband
and i have kind of just opted out of
getting that
um
i'm on baby step number two i have about
two more credit cards left to pay off
but my concern is if i'm out of work by
thanksgiving will i want to
put a hold off of paying off debt and
save every penny i get or do i want to
pay off more debt but have less really
wiggle room if i were to lose my job you
need to put your total money makeover on
hold
and you know need to go get a new job
today yeah start looking right now don't
even wait for that shoe to drop
it's coming
it's coming and you've already made your
decision
and so you just need to act today
don't wait the the thing that can happen
is is that we live in uh we think that
uh
that the calvary is coming and someone's
gonna solve this for us
and they're not
they're not coming
yeah you know you really do know what's
going to happen so don't walk around
acting like it's not going to happen
yeah
and so it's time it's time for you to go
on and you need to go on today yeah you
don't need to wait on thanksgiving yeah
and by the way julie this is a great job
market right now yeah it's perfect
timing i mean you're gonna get an
upgrade what do you make now
uh so what's funny is i've been working
at this company for two years but this
month i got promoted into a new role and
i make about 47 now with my raise cody
what kind of
work um i was an executive assistant and
now i kind of work um
as a
low-level consultant i would say within
the organization
correct yes okay
specializing in what operations
marketing um administration
yeah yeah well look uh you know how many
cups so you were such a good you're such
a good administrative assistant that
you're teaching the rest of them now
yeah
is that what it amounts to
yeah i would say so okay yeah all right
yeah so you probably can land a position
at making 60 as a high-end
administrative assistant if you want to
do that again
yeah because you've not only been you've
not only been a world-class assistant
you've also taught them
my fear is that a lot of companies are
going to be moving towards this new um
like in-person hybrid model which is
totally fine but having the mandated
vaccine within that is what scares me
there's some that are the big ones and
some but most of us aren't and do your
homework on the front end you can ask
around town you don't have to because
this because you've had this experience
at one place does not mean it's going to
be the norm
that's just not happening
it's only the big companies that are
optics concerned that are the huge mega
companies that are doing this stupid
butt stuff and the rest of them are
going no people are grown ups they get
to make their own decisions
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage tony and ruth ann are
with us hey guys how are you we're doing
great how are you dude welcome welcome
good to have you where do you guys live
in delafield wisconsin just west of
milwaukee milwaukee area welcome to
nashville thank you and all the way down
here to do a debt-free screen we are how
much have you paid off
346 thousand dollars wow how long did
that take 34 months wow you kicked it
that's amazing and your range of income
during that time uh we started out right
around 180 and we ended about 250. wow
nice job what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a sourcing manager
for a large
tool company
and i'm a swim coach and health coach
okay wow good stuff what kind of debt
was the 346 thousand
it was our mortgage
[Applause]
house and everything yes looking at
weird people
way to go guys you have a paid for house
we do that is so cool what's this house
worth
about 600k
that's so fun
so what made you decide to pay it off 34
months ago
well back in 2005 we moved back to
wisconsin i retired from the military
and uh
we bought the house and in 2014 my
daughter and i my wife talked my
daughter and i into going to fpu with
our church
so we went and we didn't have a lot of
debt at the time so
getting through the first couple baby
steps was easy
um then we built up our emergency fund
and then in 2018
uh we refinanced our house to a 15-year
yeah following your plan
and we said all right no more enough's
enough we want to be completely
debt-free so we went after it every
extra dime we got and we
put toward the house so the whole
financial peace university thing tripped
you up made you do it yes exactly
eventually
well you went right down the baby steps
it sounds like absolutely well done
yeah i got to ask when we see this kind
of a jump in income what what what
allowed for the 70 000 bump
well uh mainly it was me taking a new
job and also uh bonuses thrown in there
as well nice so you get so you got a new
job did you did you look for that did
they come after you and what was the
intentionality there it was a little of
both
nice it was great timing good for you
man dave that's the bigger shovel that's
one way to get a bigger shot because i
get promoted ding ding nice 34 months
later the house is done
very cool thank you for your service by
the way yes welcome and uh so uh
wow what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you guys did it
um
i'm gonna take this one i'm the free
spirit he's the nerd but it was his
spreadsheets
and it was working as a team because
there were some times when we had to say
no and our friends just thought we were
nuts because interest rates are really
low on on mortgages and uh
um
we were really intentional yeah every
extra dime
went to the mortgage we didn't even
think about
using it for anything else so we have a
lot of household uh
updates that we need to do that we have
put off and uh now you're ready we're
ready yeah and we can pay cash make you
a little list of them and start plowing
through them huh yes and you know what
you're never too old and it's not too
late because i i know we're a little bit
older for this uh debt-free scream and
uh how old are you
late 50s okay so um
you know we hear a lot of stories of
younger people that are amazing but uh
it's never too late to start this and
the grass does feel much better under
your feet when that house is paid off
yeah so you were like 55 years old when
it started 54 years old when you started
this yeah and now we have lots of
options and i would have to say that
discipline is freedom and a lot of
people don't look at it that way oh yeah
that's all that's good yeah the line
from the health coach yeah yeah
good it is freedom you're right that's
very good
how's it feel
very liberating yes it feels awesome
to know that we're in charge of our
future
financial and otherwise i mean um
it's we're very excited to be in the
position that we're in we became
everyday millionaires uh
about two years ago during this process
so
that helps and
you know so you've got uh how much in
your nest egg right now in your in your
retirement uh we're at about 1.6 and
then the house is worth six correct yeah
so about 2.2 anyway
total about 1.6 total oh total so about
about a million in the in the retirement
accounts right exactly all right wow
look at you
and how much of this did you inherit
zero zero precisely nothing yes yeah
and um you're probably like me you want
to be nice but when people say stuff
like you're so lucky you want to
strangle them big time luck had nothing
to do with it it didn't it didn't um but
you know what luck seems to follow
people that work the plan yeah i do have
to say that you know um
so well i mean and discipline is freedom
yes it is luck is uh luck follows people
who um have some discipline and do hard
work and all those kinds of things
yeah the harder i work the luckier i get
i've heard you know that kind of stuff
yeah you know i got to address that
because it drives me nuts there's no
luck at all
i got to tell you you all put yourself
in the right positions the discipline
puts yourself in positions to where good
things come to you right yeah you know
there's something you know we've heard
the phrase good things come to those who
wait waiting is a form of discipline
that's what you guys did so i mean i
just you guys are amazing and you're the
health coach i mean absolutely yeah and
i i tell that to my clients also yeah
you know and what gets what gets
measured gets managed and so i think
it's really important
he is mr excel spreadsheet
he can tell you how much we're going to
have in the bank 2028 because it's um
but it's really important to measure
and check where things are going so
nothing nothing moves unless it's
measured yeah that's exactly right i
agree
well done you guys thank you thank you
so great so fun so fun what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
well having a plan and sticking to it
and we did it together yeah i mean we
had we had our moments we had our you
know
discussions on things we'd get a bonus
and it's like okay
can we please just get one little thing
but we didn't we did we just
yeah and we we took vacations and things
like that so it wasn't like we didn't
uh have some fun along the way yeah we
were like you're so what's the first big
project on the house you're gonna do now
the floors the floors you know what my
husband didn't want me to share this but
i'm gonna we got duct tape holding down
some carpet in our house yeah and we are
getting and you're worth 1.6 million
dollars yeah with duct tape on your
carpet
you might be a redneck if yeah
if you got duct tape holding your carpet
down wow
yes
i love it yeah so a new hardwoods or
what we're just gonna have them
refinished oh okay and they get new
carpet yeah that carpet that duct tape
garbage got to go i'm just saying yeah
don't even know what it is but it's got
to go yeah and you can just write the
check and you won't even feel it yes no
house payment at all yeah
congratulations so proud of you guys
you're great you're heroes
well well done very well done we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you've completely changed your legacy
and uh changed the whole process here
very well done and a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody else and pay it forward and
keep these keep these ideas moving and
keep creating more and more of these
baby step millionaires like you guys i'm
so proud of you well done well done all
right here we go tony and ruth ann in
milwaukee wisconsin
346 thousand 000 paid off in 34 months
house and everything
making 180 to 250 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
different different yeah
that is amazing
wow
yeah these baby stuff millionaires are
coming out of the woodwork nowadays um
you know but dave ramsey's only for the
poor people he can't really help you if
you want to become wealthy
you know you've heard that right so uh
yeah it's hilarious but yeah there's
millionaires everywhere by the way
what's interesting about that kind of
critique that i'd like to just take on
right now and smash it dave ramsey
didn't do anything in the story or the
story in the second hour or the third
hour every hour of every ramsay show we
as a company showed people a clear path
but these people did the work yeah the
whole interview has nothing to do with
you i didn't get any people that
attacked you i did not give them any
money there's no scamming people are
actually doing the work and you hear
these stories you get fired up because
they came together two different
personalities came together for a shared
goal and that's that's just that's what
it's about their dreams their future
their peace their freedom that's how it
works you're listening to the ramsay
show
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 16 3
commit to the lord whatever you do and
he will establish your plans
john maxwell said the reality is that
you will never get much done
unless you go ahead and do it before
you're ready
that's the truth
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
april is with us april is in state
college pennsylvania hi april what's up
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure how can i help so my question
is i
completed baby step 7 back in 2018. i
just turned 34 years old
and today i have a net worth of about
1.7 million dollars way to go
thank you but my question is
the one baby step i've always skipped is
about saving for kids college because i
don't have any children at this point
but
well now i'm kind of at the point where
i know i want kids within the next five
years or so and should i open a 529
account in my name and then transfer it
down the road like once i have children
would there be any would that be useful
or not
probably wouldn't fool with it honestly
you're in great shape you don't have to
do that but if you want to there's
nothing wrong with what you're doing
technically it'll work
uh because 529s are transferable to
family members
and you would have tax-free growth on
that money you know it's basically a
roth for education right
and so that in that sense it's it's an
interesting strategy
um
the downside is is if for some reason
you did not end up having children you
have this money trapped in an education
fund
and you really you're gonna have to
transfer it to somebody else in the
family you know to be able to use it
without the penalties you're not gonna
get the tax-free growth in that case
obviously
so uh
i probably i'm trying to think
it's not a bad strategy i
just uh there's something about saving
for a kid that's not here yet i probably
wouldn't do it
okay yeah i was just thinking because i
know i either want kids either
biological or for some reason i couldn't
then adoption but yeah i mean i don't
doubt that you have children one one way
or the other i don't have any doubt of
that whatsoever but um
i i think that there's um
the little bit of gain
the the money is trapped for one purpose
and the little bit of gain you would
have
before doing that this early is probably
not worth trapping it
i i you know and the and so if it was
sharing to me we probably wouldn't do it
you got 1.7 million dollars your kids
going to college don't worry about it
yeah you know and you're responsible and
killing it they got you to this point in
the first place yeah so you got you got
plenty of time
um
it's a it's uh uh
yeah i probably wouldn't give up the
freedom on the money for the little bit
of gain that you're gonna get from it
jesse is in charlotte north carolina hi
jesse welcome to ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
i have a
couple properties one for rental
property and then my personal property
and the rental property is
is essentially paid off or will be short
with about
10 000 left on it and our personal
property
has 174
000 left on it and so my question for
you is
there's kind of one or three three
routes that i'm thinking um
one is sell the rental property and then
just pay off our property and keep
whatever extra cash after we sell it
the other is just to keep it since we
don't
you know we don't really have a mortgage
after the next couple months on it and
keep that cash flow it rents for about
1500 a month and then just essentially
debt snowball
our personal property
uh and then the other option i think of
as a potential refi just to pay off my
personal and then keep the the rental in
the llc and just treat it as a separate
business so that's where my my question
is for you what route would you
recommend what's your household income
uh about a hundred thousand okay so if
you just leave things like they are
you're on you don't have any other debt
other than this right
correct and if you're putting 15 of your
income aside for retirement how quickly
do you pay off 174 000 making 100 grand
um i think we could pay it off in the
next few years
four to five years
okay
that's what i would do and i just keep
the rental
if it was going to be 15 years for you
to be able to get out of this because
everything was so tight you know i'd
probably dump the rental and get your
house paid off but i think you can pay
it off in four to five years and that's
if you don't get any raises
right
okay yeah you're pouring all of your you
know your spare cash
from the rental income and from your
household income
beyond 15 of your income going into
retirement all the spare cash you can
find without choking your family down to
nothing and we're just gonna start
paying off that house and you're gonna
have it paid for in five years
okay that's 30 grand a year
40 grand a year yeah i mean i it's
definitely doable the the market right
now is very i guess hot so to speak
that's why i was curious is it like a
good time to sell and just keep what you
can or just hold on to it well the only
reason i would sell is if i thought it
was going to go down
okay it's not going to go down it's just
just really really shot up
quickly and so all the real estate that
i had on my balance sheet a year ago is
now worth a lot more i kind of like that
i'm not selling nothing
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna just
smile about all these increases in value
that i've got so true and by the way the
rents are going up too yeah
so your income's going up there as well
jesse what you're hearing from dave is
the long view versus right now and right
this is a temptation for people dave
it's like oh i cash out now but you look
at the long term run those numbers out
as the value increases the rent over all
those years versus your one time sum
yeah i mean the value is going to
continue to increase it's probably not
going to increase at the same rate it
has in the last couple of years have
been unbelievable correct last couple
years but um
you know it's a good play to hold them
yeah if you can and i think you're in a
position you can sam is with us sam's in
bismarck north dakota hi sam how are you
hey dave
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
hey um
yeah i had a question i'm debating
on going back to school
to become a crop duster
and i'm up here in north dakota working
uh saving money to be able to do that
and i was just
uh wondering if it's the right
uh step to take to do that or what's a
crop duster make what kind of money do
you make
well the first couple years
not very much i think which is it's a
seasonal thing during the summer so
you i think 20 to 30 grand your first
couple seasons and then after you get
uh
acclimated to it and better then you
know you make up to a hundred thousand
dollars in
six months what's it gonna cost for you
to get trained
well i checked out a school down in
georgia and it was 50 grand and it takes
four three to four months yeah
i would keep researching i i would keep
searching and researching and looking
for anybody and everybody who's
reputable and see if we can get that
cost shaved off and see if we get a
better deal
and then the question is how bad do you
want to do this if if there wasn't any
money to pay for it would you be jumping
on this right away how excited are you
to be a crop duster
well um
i thought about it for a few years and
uh i went down there and
checked the school out and rode in one
and man after we took off got up in the
air and dove down in the field i you
know thought i was on cloud nine i was
uh all about it so there you go so keep
on saving brother keep on saving okay
don't you quit all right hey look
you're gonna have to save for it and i
love that you said save because it's
gonna take a little longer but here's
the deal that feeling is going to happen
to you over and over and over again and
you just keep your mindset on how that
felt that time you got up there how much
money you're eventually going to make
and that will allow you to keep the
persistence you have to get a pilot's
license right yeah he's got to get
trained for that you have to not only
get a pilot's license but you also have
to learn how to actually do this type of
maneuver correct
well you got to get your private pilot
and then your
commercial pilot
and then after that there's an ag
program which is what this school they
do all that but they're specifically an
ag
program that shows you you know your
turns and how to dive in the field and
all that that's amazing i've never heard
of that that's so cool yeah
you have to learn how to do everything
somewhere so that's interesting wow the
answer is yes go to it yeah pay cash for
it yep and shop around make sure there's
more there's got to be more than one
place teaching it make sure you're not
overpaying
you got sucked into somebody else's
dream
[Music]
that's the truth uh ken coleman good
hour good job james shiles and kelly in
the booth i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com slash survey or
text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you